welcome back to our s of the UN
Secretary General today took the
unprecedented step of invoking article
99 of the UN Charter calling on the UN
Security Council to avert a humanitarian
catastrophe in Gaza it comes after UN
Human Rights Chief vulka Turk described
situation as apocalyptic with a
heightened risk of atrocity crimes last
time my next guest was on the show she
didn't accept there was a humanitarian
crisis in Gaza so I welcome back now to
zei hotelli Who is the isra ambassador
to the UK and I'll ask straight off the
top Ambassador if I may have you changed
your mind do you now accept there is a
humanitarian crisis in Gaza there is no
doubt there is humanitarian crisis in
Gaza but Hamas needs to be blamed for
that because just today we saw Hamas
taking over humanitarian Aid trucks
taking food from the people of Gaza
taking over every single thing including
medicine so this is Kamas behavior that
is preventing the people of Gaza to
receive this humanitarian Aid so we
still see Hamas as the main barrier to
give the people of Gaza the humanitarian
Aid that Israel allows to let to get
into
Gaza but look I as you know I support
Israel's right to defend itself I think
Hamas by what it did on October the 7th
showed that it has to be removed and
they live amongst the civilian
population it's it's an incredibly
difficult War to prosecute if you're
Israel I accept all of those things but
the Stark facts are that over 15,000
people have now been killed in Gaza
already in just over two months of which
four to 5 thousand are beli to be
children you cannot look at these scenes
in Gaza and not feel the same way that
we all do but this is a an extraordinary
Slaughter of innocent people as you go
after terrorists Pierce I totally
doesn't expect accept what you're
describing at the moment because things
think about how much efforts Israel is
doing to make sure the Palestinians will
get to designated areas in the southwest
area of Gaza in order to have a safer
places shelters humanitarian Aid all
these things Israel is doing something
that not in the past other countries did
for enemy population now we are dealing
with a terror organization that as a
strategy use the people and the children
and the women as human Shields so
they're basing all their the bases all
their um military bases inside hospitals
they're basing it into unra schools
they're basing it into masks and as you
know now we are um in kanun kanun is the
city that this archive terrorist that
planned in in this calculated way this
devil plan of October 7th so we now must
finish the job of making sure Hamas
won't control the Gaza Strip there is no
other way if you want a better future
for for Palestinian children as well as
Israeli
children but where where are all these
gazans going to live when this is over
you've pretty well leveled the north of
Gaza you're now going into the South to
do the same there you're shoehorning
these million several million people
into a tiny area where the facilities
for them are truly awful as every
independent assessor is saying but what
happens after this I mean if most of
Gaza gets destroyed and tens of thousand
thousands of gazin are killed what life
is there left for them after this well
that's a very good question you're
actually referring to the day after the
war so first of there is still a big
task to Israel to make sure the
underground tunnel city is destroyed and
as I'm carrying this to remind everyone
there are over
138 innocent people kept hostage in
Kamas hands including 15 women and by
the way it was Matthew Miller the
spokesperson of the state department
that said the reason Hamas didn't
releasee them in the last p is because
they're very much terrified from the
idea these women will speak up for all
the atrocities the rape the systematic
rape Kamas committed against innocent
women and uh I really appreciate the
fact you spoke up for this sexual
violence but I want to tell you I feel
sometimes like Jewish women doesn't
count when you think about the world
silence when you think about your
organization saying nothing about this
systematic rape Hamas mutualized women
it it it there was a necrofilia there
was a innocent young women from a music
festival that had a gang rape so those
kind of things we must make sure the
world won't be silenc about and and and
I really think that this was one of
those moments of Silence that was a
disgrace to the UN organizations and for
many women organizations by not speaking
up for that so I want to remind you that
because Kamas listen didn't released our
hostages
listen on on that I completely agree
with you but but it's it's how Israel is
going about Prosecuting the war on Hamas
that is causing increasing concern and
it is unprecedented for the UN Secretary
General to invoke article 99 of the UN
Charter they've never done it before uh
this is because what he believes is a a
genuine right now safety security and
humanitarian threat which needs the
attention of the whole un Security
Council um you know this humanitarian
aspect of what is going on in Gaza is
now something that's requiring
unprecedented United Nations
intervention well obviously this is not
the case because many times in the past
there were many types of humanitarian
crisis in many places do you think mosul
didn't look like Gaza after the
Americans air strikes do you think Tokyo
after American air strikes didn't look
worse than Gaza so over 100,000 Japanese
got killed in the second world war under
American air strikes and the reason it
was it was because the Japanese
involvement in Pearl Harbor so we need
to remember who started this war Kamas
started this war and this is not in our
duty by the way in in in no way not to
protect our people this is actually our
duty to make sure Israeli children will
prot protected in the future and no one
in the International Community including
our allies the Americans the British the
Germans no one is thinking there is
other way besides making sure Hamas
infrastructure won't exist the military
machine must be destroyed and you need
to remember that Hamas brought it on his
own people 16 years of Hamas regime
since 2005 no Israel Street and they
brought just poverty and bloodshed over
the Palestinian people at the moment
Ambassador we have Israel giving us
their version of what they're doing in
Gaza and the only journalists outside of
people actually in Gaza nearly 60 of
whom have been killed which is horrific
worst death to on journalist in living
memory uh but the the international
journalists want to get in there but
they're only being allowed in if they're
with the IDF and carefully controlled
why won't you let journalists go into
Gaza and investigate this as they would
in other War zones first of all I'm sure
journalists will be allowed into the
Gaza Strip uh at the moment remember
that many parts of Gaza are still
controlled by Hamas and Hamas is
preventing from journalists to get in
and this is why IDF is actually giving
access to journalists to get in and to
see with their own eyes to be
eyewitnesses but only with the IDF and
again this is part of the reason why we
want to protect them we don't want them
to get caught in a crossfire but if
we'll go back to your question the
argument is you know Ambassador just to
pick you up on that as you know what you
may be protecting as far as they're
concerned is access to reality and you
again I just ask you is it not time to
allow foreign journalists to go in there
without being escorted Everywhere by the
IDF where clearly there's a conflict of
interest there
what they may or may not be prepared
there is something that Israel doesn't
have anything to hide what we do is a
self- protection of our people after the
BR brutal attack at 7th of October but
if we'll go back to your question about
the day after one thing we realize after
ongoing military operations and this
time wanted to be final we don't want it
to be ongoing violence Cycles in order
to make sure both Israelis and
Palestinians will have a better future
there is no doubt the the Gaza Street
must be first of all demilitarized and
the second thing is it must be
deradicalized when you think about the
education system under the UN symbol
that brought this young Palestinians to
grow up to be this monstrous terrorist
we need to stop that we need to make
sure the next generation will receive
education of respecting the other side
just like Israelis are raised an idea
that in the other side there are humans
they they must stop dehumanizing Jews
and I I want to tell you something I
thought anti-em ism is out of this world
when I saw in
2023 the presidents of of us you know IV
league universities still don't
understand well I'm going to come to
that the scale of antisemitism I'm come
to that with my I'm coming to that
specifically with my next guest actually
that's why I'm going to cut you off on
that Ambassador listen I appreciate you
coming back on the show I think we
should have a regular dialogue through
this war like I said to you you don't
have to you know justify October the 7th
and Israel's right to defend itself
after that it's it's how you're doing it
that is the matter of concern now and I
appreciate you coming on and answering
some questions thank you very much very
much